in other breaking news in a developing
story out of uganda two explosions have
taken place in the capital kampala
one blast took place near the central
police station checkpoint and the second
near the parliamentary building
catherine soy is covering the story
she's joining us from the kenyan capital
nairobi catherine what more are you
hearing about these explosions and
any word of
casualties
well the situation is still very fluid
we know that the police have cordoned
off those scenes where the blasts
happened and government
offices that are around those areas we
know that parliamentarians
have been evacuated from parliament
buildings
one of the explosions happened very
close to parliament so sessions
that were going on have been called off
we know that there are unbalanced
ambulances that are taking people
to different hospitals
we do not know yet about casualties but
i have been told that the mayor of the
city has confirmed that a police man
and several other people have been
killed
but we are still waiting for um official
uh updates uh from the police they say
that they are still investigating the
impact uh of this blast we know that
buildings around some of these areas
have been windows have been shattered uh
reporters are talking about bloody sins
so we're still waiting for an update
from the police about what's going on
but like i said the situation still very
fluid yeah and we're looking at the live
picture right now from from kampala
itself catherine but why would the uh
this police station in particular as
well as
the vicinity of the parliamentary
building be targeted in this way
well these are targets that are normally
used uh by people who want to make a
statement and you know darren this is
not the first time kampala is facing
such another such an attack last
month on the 23rd of october
the restaurant was attacked there was an
explosion a waitress was killed
as well and two other people were
seriously injured two days after that
attack a bus about 30 kilometers away
from kampala was also attacked the
perpetrator the attacker died and
several people were injured the police
came up and blamed a group called the
adf the allied democratic forces this is
a group
that is based right now in the
democratic republic of congo the eastern
part of it has been attacking villages
and killing civilians it has its roots
in uganda but we have not seen them
really carrying out attacks in uganda in
in recent years but now the um
government says
that several people who are attacked
from uh who are arrested and are being
detained from that attack have led them
to believe that the adf carried these
attacks the attacks themselves were
acclaimed by isis uh but the government
insists it is adf that carried out the
tax so people are worried about what's
going on people are worried about these
targets um you know police targets
parliament government targets and also
soft targets
and you know people wondering what is
going on police are saying uh keep calm
do not come to the to the vicinity of
the explosion uh scenes but like i said
people are extremely worried in kampala
there's a lot of uncertainty right now
okay thank you catherine sawyer giving
us that update from nairobi